un professeur pour chaque classe le
recrutement s'est bien passé pour les
Yvelines c'est l'une des annonces
d'Étienne champion le nouveau recteur de
l'académie de Versailles parmi les
autres informations le RCD le
remplacement de courte durée nous
travaillons à ce que au maximum des
formations puissent être proposées en
dehors des périodes de classe nous
sommes travaillons aussi à favoriser le
remplacement grâce à toute série de
dispositifs et notamment le dispositif
nouveau que nous on appelle le pacte et
qui permet grâce à une rémunération
supplémentaire à certains enseignements
saints enseignants pardon volontaire de
s'engager pour faire justement ces
remplacements de courte durée un plan
français et un plan mathématique se
déploie ainsi qu'un plan maternel en
renforçant les savoirs fondamentaux dès
le premier cycle une rentrée
particulière aussi pour certains élèves
verrier roi dont leur école a brûler en
juillet dernier ils seront accueillis à
l'école régionale de premier degré la
prise en charge de cette situation qui
est très particulière parce que
évidemment elle elle touche un cas
extrême où l'école a été détruite et ne
pouvait évidemment pas être construite
en deux mois c'est un véritable travail
partenarial extrêmement fort avec la
région avec l'ensemble des collectivités
avec évidemment l'éducation nationale
nous serons très présents nous l'avons
été pendant tout l'été dans le
département plus de 300000 élèves vont
faire leur rentrée près de 1200
établissements les accueillent